well good afternoon so I'm going to talk
about oceanography broadly within the
field of oceanography you might hear of
like marine biology and chemical
oceanography I practice a domain called
physical oceanography so we care about
things like currents winds energy
momentum those are the quantities that
physical oceanography cares about and of
course it interacts with the other
branches let me just give you some
background of where I'm coming from in
this sort of field so I'm a math physics
computer science float a person physical
oceanography is a great domain to be in
because you get to practice all of those
skills and and bring them to bear on
problems so it's a nice domain to be
working in
but I'm highly motivated by the team
that I happened to be with I do physical
oceanography because that's the path
that I someways fell down I could be
doing astrophysics I could be doing
something in oil and gas I could be
doing anything I just happen to be doing
physical oceanography a lot of my work
if you sort of look at sort of papers
that I've written have pictures like
that squiggles on a page these are all
something called internal gravity waves
very briefly the ocean is stratified
what does that mean it means as you go
deeper to the ocean it gets saltier and
it gets colder because of that it also
gets denser and in the same way that you
can have a wave on the interface between
the air and the water on the surface of
the ocean we can have waves inside the
ocean between all those different layers
of density internal waves are everywhere
in the ocean they're everywhere in in
the atmosphere and they're important for
understanding how mixing and energy and
momentum gets transferred in the ocean
that's the background let me give you an
example the kind of work that I found
myself typically doing so I would do lab
experiments and what does it mean to a
lab experiment in oceanography it means
you take an aquarium and you fill it up
with salt water and the salt water is
not one density but many many densities
changing from top to bottom and I study
these waves in my lab and typically the
way that I study these things is I have
you think of an aquarium I have a
pattern in the background so I I having
a little vignette Emmel on the on the
left there you see these these sort of
Hashi gray things if you zoom in there
bunch of dots basically and I videotape
light
traveling through the tank with that
pattern in the background and so three
frames those are three successive frames
of video from an experiment and of
course you don't see much at all but the
point is if you process those imagery so
that that pattern of dots you can see
very slight changes in where the dots
appear to be this is a property of index
of refraction changing when density
changes and you can tease out where the
waves happened to be so I would design
these workflows where I take a few
thousand images and do pairwise cross
correlations between them and extract
out the ways that's that red and blue
sort of thing basically the water going
up water going down you'd have to do
various spectral filtering on it and
different spatial filters to tease out
the different kinds of waves so even
though you don't see anything there's
actually three different kinds of waves
going on there at three different
frequencies and then you study it in
some way you look at the growth of the
waves or how they propagated or how they
broke cause mixing that was the basic
the basic instance of this now I liked
building these computational pipelines
taking some raw data product and merging
it together and repeating it over and
over over multiple property' parameters
these actual experiments would consume a
moderate amount of data and I think this
particular work is about 10 years old so
the yellow but half a terabyte one
terabyte of of images so thousands and
thousands of images that all sort of
looked grayish and building these
pipelines is what I really like to do
the thing though is an academic you may
have heard this this phrase the publish
or perish model what we're measured on
is asking good novel research questions
and then publishing papers and repeating
the stuff in the middle the actual work
of science acquiring the data from a
numerical model or an experiment doing
something with it doing the
visualization wait you know that can be
delegated
that's what graduate students are for
right we that the science the true
science I'm seeing very sophistical here
it's the science II question I don't
like that part I can do that part but I
like the middle part I like working with
data and interpreting and visualizing it
and if you ask
four or five years ago I would have said
oh it's just too bad there's no such
thing as a job or I could just take data
and clean it up and visualize it and
interpret it shucks and then of course
I've discovered that we've given this
field a name we call it data science and
we've rebranded it so you now can walk
around and call yourself a data
scientist and feel pretty cool and you
can find people that look at the
scientific process the details and it's
all built in there and so I I'm one of
those happy people who live right in the
middle of sort of like a standard drew
Conway Venn diagram for data science I
both come from math math background I do
lots of ocean science and I've always
been a Packer kadak kind of guy so I
bril vote those things together so what
I've been trying to do is work at the
interface between sort of the tech
sector and my physical oceanography
science sector to see where I can get
some some overlap both to help the
science and potentially train my
students so they can go off and work at
other industries we have tons of data
and oceanography this is new
historically where we got oceanography
data from was we go on a boat boats are
expensive you lower down a sensor like a
thermometer and you wheel back up and
you get a number
each number was precious it was very
very important we're getting more and
more where we have these autonomous
systems basically they'll call floats
the thing on the yellow is an Argo float
we toss them into the ocean there's a
few hundred of them thousands of them
sort of floating around the ocean right
now about three thousand four thousand
and they just float around the ocean and
every 10 days they they sit down to
about two kilometers and then pop back
up to the surface they phone home
through the radium phone network and
they say that's the density or the
stratification that's temperature and
salinity content top to bottom of the
ocean and then they repeat and so each
one of these floats as it moves being
carried around the ocean produces
sequences like the picture you see on
the left but what you're basically
looking at is a function of depth and it
must be temperature temperature I said
I've got rid of the scales for
completeness so that's just looking at
temperature and what you're seeing is a
seasonal cycle so that's 2002 2003
four and the floats are moving they're
not stationary so getting all this data
together is a challenge because a lot of
the techniques a lot of the textbook
stuff on oceanographic data analysis is
designed for you have a hundred numbers
and you're trying to tease out
information it's not designed for having
three thousand series like this that are
spatially varying so there's a little
bit of knowledge and balance between the
data we have and the skills most
physical oceanographers have in
numerical modeling it's even worse in a
sense so numerical modeling the idea is
use a computer to try and simulate what
an ocean does and and you do these
things by using large numerical grids
and we're at a stage right now we're
simulating the ocean at a quarter
degrees routine we do things at a tenth
of a latitude longitude degree it's
pretty common and please for regional
models a thirtieth of a degree is
standard and we're moving towards to be
able to what a thirtieth the degree
across the entire globe the thing that's
when you're doing ocean stuff ocean and
climate are really tied together you
want to run these things for a
relatively long time not just three
months not just three years but maybe
thirty years or a hundred years and
every time step may only be a few
minutes you generate very very large
data sets and it's very call what you
want to do is is run these fifty or a
hundred times to get some statistics try
and generate it out you generate
datasets on the order of tens to
hundreds of terabytes would be one
particular models output and so we need
to learn about skills or develop ways of
analyzing that kind of data just to give
you a flavor here of what do I mean by
by the data I'll just show you a quick a
couple quick little slides here if I can
I had no idea lighthouses juice greens
just greens that's what's going on here
yeah so so very briefly here would be a
snapshot of sort of what we'd call the
the sea surface temperature the idea is
you can see all those little squiggles
and rolls this is basically
southern ocean a little sector model
that we ran and of course near the
equator it's warmer than Antarctica it's
colder but all that small scale
structure is representing the mixing in
the model that's what we care about how
does the mixing actually occur we look
at things like temperature we look at
things like sea surface current so even
within not only looking at temperature
and salinity you're also looking at how
fast the water is moving north south
east west and up down you've got all
these sign these sort of structures and
where the technology is going is even
though that looks relatively complicated
if you zoom in on a region if you run a
higher resolution model so more data
points in X and Y and Zed you get finer
and finer structures so the point is
relative to the out the sides left and
right which are lower resolution
versions of it if I run this thing you
get all this very small scale feature
now small scale feature the outside is
probably a grit scale of like 10 to 15
kilometers the small scale feature is
like 2 to 3 kilometers that means you
would take an entire 2 kilometers square
block of ocean and you say that
temperature is 2.3 degrees
you just you categorize the whole thing
as being one number in reality you have
turbulence in these systems the real
physics goes down to centimeters a few
millimeters are the number of scales you
need to be able to really resolve and
what we're students resolving some of
these small scale processes so in terms
of numerical modeling that the the
challenge is how do you begin to work
with this kind of data data that's on
the orders of tens and hundreds of
terabytes historically and by
historically I mean like six years ago
the model would be you run the model of
supercomputer and then they just
download it to your workstation doesn't
scale when you're dealing with multi
terabyte data sets the all the big
compute was done on the model the models
are all written in Fortran a lot of bash
scripting that sort of drop dies them
and then the actual analysis is
typically done by scientists
postgraduate students on single
stations and if you need a more powerful
workstation you just bought a more
powerful workstation and that was the
way of scaling it the problem is as we
get to these data sets which are even
more volumous and more interesting
it doesn't fit on one machine now of
course this is a problem that's across
multiple branches of science multi
branches of Industry the big data
problem how do I deal with problems that
don't fit on a single machine there are
a few hacks like you could downscale the
data but you miss something if you
downscale it so I'm interested in
solving that problem of how do we ask
questions how do we deal with data at
that scale okay so this is it
large-scale data's are not unique to if
you're not a fee-based what I just said
this problem is being tackled obviously
not just by me but there's lots of
people within the Geoscience field I'll
give a little shout out to a project
called pan geo data this has some
funding in the US and it's sort of sort
of growing the idea here is if you
imagine the software stack not a number
of numbs focus sponsored projects
they've heard of like biopython and Sun
PI and whatever imagine a project which
is climate oceany PI we're calling it
pan geo something in that space that
would sit on the top of the numeric
scientific software stack they would
solve these problems for the community
I've already talked about Big Data but
there's two other problems that pan geo
is trying to solve one is the mismatch
between the scientists doing the work
the technical skills they have whether
or not this be programming or
infrastructure or or working with larger
data sets there's a real mismatch
between what they use which is like
Fortran and maybe MATLAB and Excel and
bash scripting that's it that's the
whole set and what's out there in
industry what many of you use on a daily
basis and the other thing is
reproducibility in science is sort of a
big thing we should be able to do it we
can't no no Big Data of course this is
everywhere it's it was it was a giant
buzzword still some sense is and one of
the outcomes from Big Data as being a
industry buzzword as there has been a
lot of activity in that space so I
borrowed this the
a 2016 slide and I just sort of a
Bridget just some of the commercial or
open source products in the Big Data
field a lot of that are analytics
platforms that you'll see somewhere in
sort of at the top right there data
science platforms some of the things
that we use Jupiter's in there somewhere
pythons obviously in there somewhere all
these other sort of technologies and one
of the things that I've been sitting is
what of these technologies can be
leveraged back towards the science to
give us some payoff how could we use
these kind of things and the flipside is
what kind of training could I give to my
students and my colleagues that I work
with who are doing an academic degree
but like many of you you do something
science II and then you have to get a
job so how do I merge those things back
together so I work in that space of
trying these things out seeing what's
what's best of breed what would work
well for us this idea about
reproducibility I'll just give you a
quick summary about what I mean by that
repeal ability okay so what so we get
home meals that's my daughter my wife
made these wonderful meatballs and I
said that's great
can we have them again and the problem
is the actual details of what went into
that meatball and the sauce not
repeatable because we're not sure
exactly when it went into them the first
time we're really good second I wasn't
so much and that's sort of back and
forth so I'm gonna call that
repeatability the ability for you when
you're doing the data science pipeline
or a workflow can you get the same
answer again and in some ways you're
like cool that's gonna be easy just
rerun the code if the code is a whole
sequence of steps that are spanned over
multiple months lots of things can
change in the interim in the in the in
term you know this reproducibility at
least in the scientific context would be
if I give you my scientific stack and I
said well rerun this and come up with
the same graph conclusion paper you
should be able to do
this in a purely computational
environment this should be an easy win
it is not because we don't have a great
way of sharing my whole solution to you
it's because it's not just a little
snippet of code it's my whole
infrastructure stack is what I've really
got to be sharing with you and there are
solutions for that but they're not
widespread or explored at all in the
geosciences this this problem of working
with code so here's just sort of a joke
that a typical graduate student would
look at it's all in there right I should
be able to build off what a previous
scientist has done but it's usually
poorly documented maintainability is an
issue it's not really commented a lot of
self-taught programmers read all soft
self talk from programmers in the hard
sciences so it's a challenge to make
these things work some of the
technologies that I've been exploring in
sort of my software stack to bring these
things together
have been things like get version
control hopefully widespread in this
room but in my community I can give a
talk on what is version control and
people go oh that exists like yes yes
that's exists and we should all use it I
open-source I still work with a
community where a MATLAB license is sort
of a given oh I'll get a grant and
putting two or three or four thousand
dollars per year to a MATLAB license is
a is an assumed thing you make the pitch
going open-source it's free people like
that because it saves them two or three
thousand dollars or more depending on
how you've done it I think we're still
trying to work out ways of saying well
what could we do about taking some of
that money which we would have given to
math works or Wolfram or any other
supplier and give it to the open source
community so that's a discussion we're
hoping about in terms
well known bring those in and I do a lot
of stuff with sort of Jupiter Jupiter
lab notebooks and things like that so
just very briefly these technologies as
said I think you're familiar with them
broadly that it's cartoon but that
directory is very common when you go
interact with practicing scientists they
practicing everybody's that that that's
their solution backup is just duplicate
and no history about what goes through
so that's very very common so just
introducing the idea of version control
not even for collaboration I try and get
people to move eventually to
collaboration but really just
collaborating with yourself I have a
laptop I've got a lab machine I've got a
supercomputer just getting those three
code sets to be consistent that can be a
win for a lot of people so trying to
equip practicing scientists with those
skills I said for their own benefit but
also when they go and interact with you
as colleagues they're coming in with
some knowledge doing a lot of stuff in
the in the Python scientific stack I've
been in that stack in terms of a user
2005 2006 so I sort of stumbled in when
numpy was just becoming to become the
dominant language so this is some of
Jacob and pluses slides from PI clock
2017 just sort of showing the pieces
that are in there and I said this pan
geodata thing that I'm working on with
some other people it is trying to fill
in the and many many more but but I use
all of these tools up and down the
software stack as you probably know
science prior to Python actually still
today so here's an earlier quote from
David Beasley scientists work with a lot
of different tools they're typically
quite different they don't interface
together different packages different
databases disposal is a shion's and
getting them to work together can be a
lot of work if you're doing science
presumably you should be spending a
significant fraction of your time most
of your time you know doing science
that's not where the time sink actually
is so what am I
the Royal but myself in is trying to
make this easier more time less code
that more time for science less time for
code for the scientists point of view
but work as that that interface back and
forth of course the reason I think or
one of the reasons that the Python has
really taken take taken off is it's just
that it has that open ethos that people
are able to go and see what it does I
can create a distribution and send it to
you and you can run in your own machine
people can try it out turns out it often
works as good or better than many of the
proprietary solutions and so this is
just exploded not just me but across the
community and many communities those who
haven't switched yet those individuals
sort of in the science community in
oceanography and other divisions if they
are still MATLAB based and I work with
them they're like yeah I am but I wanted
to switch to Python can you help me so
that's coming like across the board
in terms of other technologies that I
I'm interested in I'm playing with and
I'm sort of interested on the more did
engineering side of things virtual
machines are good a way of wrapping up
something but but adopting this idea of
containers like docker containers into
the reproducibility pipeline for science
I think we're gonna see more abut and I
don't know if it's gonna be docker per
se it's open source there are other
technologies maybe it's some kubernetes
based thing but the idea that I can
package not just my model or my result
or my Jupiter notebook but the entire
pipeline so when I want to make
something reproducible I can send to my
colleague or a graduate student can send
to their supervisor or one group can
communicate with another and say here is
literally everything with a some degree
of certainty that it'll actually work
again
so the advantages of docker if you're
not familiar with it of course is I can
describe my infrastructure with code
that code can be checked into a version
control system and so the infrastructure
itself namely my world
what compilers have you installed
libraries how are the different machines
allocated that kind of
Tyrael can be stored and retained on a
go-forward basis i think this or some
variant of that will start to grow as we
try and solve big data in oceanography
testing frameworks one day I am going to
get my colleagues to have some sort of
automated continuous integration testing
framework we need to write some tests
first we're not quite there this will
come and of course having docker
containers in that pipeline is where I'm
where I'd like to go to but I'm not
quite there when I work with my own
colleagues trying to encourage them to
go down that route a lot of its you have
to build it to demonstrate how it would
look and then people can adapt the
thorough need so I'm doing some of that
and my final thing that I that I've been
advocating at least in my world is these
dupit notebooks things are lovely yeah
Jupiter notebooks Jupiter lab it's next
evolution that the math bit in at least
the hard sciences physics mathematics
physical oceanography we love lay tech
and the reason we love latex that's sort
of incantation of back slashes and
subsections and dollar signs is because
it doesn't math well math and Microsoft
equation editor bad math and lay tech
pretty good that little bit of being
able to render math in Jupiter solves
like 75% of the reason people code in
lay tech so if you can give them docking
and interface which I can do math math
and stuff and I can do code and I can do
the output and then I can make
interactive I think that's a major win
and I've heard it another session as
well there's a little bit of chatter in
the blog sphere and on Twitter about
people going well could this displace
things like Mathematica notebook could
it actually be what mathematics is
notebook was supposed to be could we
start making that the paper not an
add-on to a traditional PDF paper it
might be coming down the pipeline so a
lot of these technologies to to deploy
them out to actually get end-users
scientists in this case using these
things you've got to demonstrate what
they would look like in practice you
can't just
we'll go to the documentation learn
about containers learn about Jupiter
learn about Python it's awesome I know
it's awesome you know it's awesome but
you need to show people how so one of
the things I've been working on is a
product I'm gonna call Cosimo cookbook
and kazuma is the consortium of ocean
and sea ice modeling in Australia I
happen to hang out with those guys for a
year last year looked at what they were
doing and said well we can fix some of
these things and it's basically a swing
gang stinks gallery kind of things of
ocean Diagnostics these are graphs and
plots they're visualized with graphs and
plots but they're little work clothes
that you could take oceanographic model
data and compute stuff with and so the
idea of this package so the Python
package in there as well is to sort of
show and demonstrate different ways of
efficiently calculating the kinds of
things that we associate physical
oceanographers need to cancel and cancel
calculate and typically its scale
working on data sets that are moderately
too large large sort of sort of size so
let me give you some specific examples
so here is an example of one of the
models that I work with so this is
something called
mam the modular ocean model it has a sea
ice component and it's a tenth of a
degree model that means you take the
entire globe and you split it up into a
checkerboard pattern where every square
is about ten kilometers by ten
kilometers so yet like a few thousand by
a few thousand grid cells in the
horizontal and then the vertical you
might have 50 or 75 layers so you've got
this cube of data that you might need to
work with and we've run this model for
60 years 70 years 80 years and of the
data that we kept we throw away most of
the data if the data is being run with a
time step of a few minutes we may only
archive one snapshot per day so the day
that we actually retain as two terabytes
10 terabytes 20 terabytes those are
typical numbers typically how much space
are systems guys will give us we keep
that's the data set that the scientists
generate these
things take a little bit of time to
generate think six seven weeks operating
at four or five thousand cores on a
machine to generate one of these
datasets they're they're reproducible
but they're sort of expensive typically
what happens is we use a file format
called netcdf netcdf is a layer that
sits on top of hdf5 hierarchical data
format self-describing arrays you could
think of it as pretty good for this
environment because we've got this
common nomenclature for the kinds of
things that we build into our into our
software pipeline or into our after a
modeling you're able to put in there the
temperature salt content the velocities
the pressures all the things you need
into one of these netcdf files and
within them the grid for the model is
built in there so metadata is built
right in there that's fine for a dataset
but what we typically do is is you'll go
to any researcher I'll have this
hierarchical tree of data so we'll have
their their model they'll have a quarter
degree version of one point one degree
version which within each version
they'll have different experiments so
kb/s 75 mint kyle which is the k we're
at a 75 layer model that's the space
case and then he did one where he did
the polar intensification that those
letters the P I that is all the metadata
we have in that directory structure to
remember that was the experiment
metadata is a novel concept these models
are typically run over several hundreds
or thousands of individual runs with big
supercomputers you don't actually get to
let your supercomputer run for four or
five weeks straight you're allowed to
run for about five hours then your job
gets soft then you wait for about five
hours to get a turn to run another five
hours so this is all on/off it's a
shared use machine so every one of these
directories is the output produced in
one temporal chunk of time four or five
hours of wall time and they generate
several hundreds of these nets EDF files
you can think about them as being all
the variables inside with what's going
on so I've got a data set
of hundreds of thousands of these netcdf
files each one containing dozens or
hundreds of variables and typically what
people do is they they have this like
for experiment in list of experiments
for run and list of run indent for
subfolder and list of like you can
imagine a loop within a loop within a
loop of the loop and there's a lot of
boilerplate on this kind of stuff so
some of the things that I've been
looking at is indexing all this thing
and building up to some sort of database
in this little example it's just white
but going through that structure so you
don't have to iterate through all those
subdirectories allowing us to do things
like queries so I could say okay of all
my data give me all the netcdf files
that have a certain pattern or a certain
variable that's in them the barrier to
learning Python is already bit of a jump
learning sequel as well probably
wouldn't take on really go over so well
so there's have an API layer on this so
from the technology point of view this
is sort of the interface that I'm
playing with as an API researcher wants
to get from a certain experiment a
certain type of variable and it sort of
goes and concatenates all those files
together to give you what you want now
I'm using a few libraries under the hood
that are doing the lion's share of the
work X array which is named numpy arrays
basically it allows me to index
variables not by first column second
column third column but I can next then
by the horizontal column the X column
the Y column the Zed column the T column
and I can name my columns like that
really nice for understanding what your
data happens to be and the other thing
that I do is these are actually all task
arrays so they're all lazily computed
and they're chunked so this is typically
fourth dimensional four dimensional data
and you want to go along any possible
different axis so this data is typically
chunked on the disk leveraging this and
showing individuals how to use chunk
data I found to be important typically
we run out of memory when we try and
load this data natively so what
researchers will do is they'll take
if you've got a hypercube of or a cube
of data the low just the top part of it
into memory do some processing write the
result out then wrote right in the next
layer if you imagine a cube of data the
problem is they're not even aware that
the data's chunked so what you end up
doing is you end up reading ten times as
much data as you need into memory
throwing away 95% of it and then reading
all them that Chuck again so a little
bit of software engineering said it's
law they're just demonstrating how these
technologies work together some of the
API says it's leveraging x-ray a lot you
can do basic sort of oceanographic
concepts on it so if I've got a data set
DSX would be the data set I can pull out
the temperature and I can say give me
everything in the Y dimension from minus
90 to plus to minus 30 that is latitude
minus 92 minus 30 I don't have to worry
about index variables so this is all
great x-ray stuff is going to do this
and then I can do things like taking the
mean in X ocean in so and Lee so I east
west and over time this calculation or
these lines of code and duper notebook
happened almost instantaneously that's
because the calculation itself is
delayed there's a product called asked
under the hood which is doing a lot of
the work for me
that's what does zonal mean potential
temperature is but don't worry about
that this is an example what gask is
doing it's basically taking that
computation figuring out a way of
computing the answer by splitting the
the problem into sub components
those sub components can be distributed
to multiple processes or multiple worker
nodes or for some network each worker
node gets a little chunk of that data
then does some aggregation operation on
it and brings it back together this is a
way of leveraging parallelization for
these highly parallelizable problems and
giving them a useful tool I'm a big fan
of Dass tasks to sort of all it's
definitely in the it's it's like spark
but it's not spark but it's all in the
Python world I happen to work in a world
which doesn't have any Java based API is
I've got to tie into so I can I can do
pretty happy working with
so here's a slide from from an anaconda
sort of work on and ask ask is this
parallel computing library which works
as its base objects there numpy and
pandas arrays that's sort of what is
dealing with or it's like those things
but it allows you to scale it's good in
the situation where you've got up to
hundreds of machines I don't know if it
scales beyond that and it's it's
relatively readable going back back and
forth so here's another example of the
kind of calculation that we would do
that this Cosmo cookbook sort of
explains and walks a researcher through
one of the things we care about is
kinetic energy so if you remember from
taking probably their high school
physics or first year university physics
kinetic energy be one-half the mass
times the velocity squared of a thing a
ball or whatever when you're talking
about fluids we don't really care about
the mass part we usually talk about the
density in the energy per unit density
so there's no mass in there there is the
one-half in that expression we often
care about what's called the Eddy
kinetic energy that is the difference
between the average velocity and the
instantaneous velocity all those little
squiggles and circles and Eddie's I
showed you before I want to know how
much energy is contained in the
squiggles the small scale flow not the
big scale flow so to calculate something
like this you would take the velocity
components in physical oceanography we
would say U and V are the East and North
components of the velocity vector
subtract off the mean in time square it
and then average it all over time to
compute this quantity on the left would
be an example of the kind and API that
I'm suggesting my community could could
use going you want something that grabs
the data you want to be very clear that
you're taking the mean in time you want
to do a mean you want to do a sum and
then you want to lazily compute all that
so you would delegate that compute step
to some - cluster so that it's being
done efficiently the the diagram on the
right hand side I've tried to make the
symbols larger basically what you do
you've got these chunks
chunks of data that live in different
files so v1 v2 in pink maybe two parts
of a single file v1 v2 in blue is
another file but I've got to sort of let
that data flow through - just doing all
the wonderful leveraging of putting
these thing through allowing me to do
these things at scale and I can grow
these things dynamically with desk I can
use multiple workers multiple clusters
to scale up or scale down these kind of
things allowing me to actually begin to
do some multi processing on my data and
I can create plots that look like
normalized change in any kinetic energy
and that would go into a paper I said
it's the part in the middle that makes
me really excited that's what I like I
don't mind doing oceanography I could do
anything what I get excited about why I
flew across the ocean to visit with all
of you is I like this stuff I like
pipelines I like data thank you very
much
[Applause]
okay so we have time for one or two
questions what isn't there okay I have
one sure so in this in this conference
in PI data we have seen some efforts and
some people talk about the efforts on on
documenting more of the open source
tools yes are you aware of any like
effort within the scientific community
to make this documentation even more
accessible to newcomers into the am I
about where so there are there are
various grants that fund certain part
parts of this we do a lot of training of
students so like the brightest students
are the one who are spending their their
days in their weeks doing this stuff
that pulling their hair out once they
have learnt that knowledge capturing
that some way so we do a lot of software
carpentry and so that's a good way of
doing on on the in ingress of people
into the field some sort of post review
you've been working in this field for a
while let's do a boot camp or a not a
boot camp and exit celebration a sprint
basically I'm doing some documentation
that probably actually would scale
pretty well across the community yeah
good awesome thanks a lot and we have
the next talk in a couple minutes so
[Applause]
you